the nominees for achievement directing
are David Lynch for blue velvet
Woody Allen for Hannah and her sisters
Roland Joffe for the mission
oliver stone for platoon
James I agree for a room with a view
I guess I hang on myself the envelope
the winner is
all of us down
thank you thank you for this Cinderella
ending but I think that through this
award you're really acknowledging the
Vietnam veteran and I think what you're
saying is it for the first time you
really understand what happened over
there and I think what you're saying is
that it should never ever in our
lifetimes happen again
and if it does then those American boys
died over there for nothing because
America learned nothing from the Vietnam
War my special thanks go to my casting
crew to Tom and Charlie and Willem to
Bob Richardson Claire Simpson
Bruno Rubio the rest of you my producers
Arnold cope Wilson Derrick Gibson
Alex Howe to Kaplan Dale died who gave
his heart and soul for the movie to
Marian Billings Andrea Jaffe follow
Agner Mike Mitchell and Bob Marshall and
to mr. John Daly who gave me a shot when
nobody else would and to my wife
Elizabeth whose deep abiding love got me
through the despair thank you